all right
i tell you something it is not
it is not every day you get aretha
franklin on your show and you're here we
wanted everything to go smoothly and the
biggest screw-up in nine years happens
downstairs what what was it i didn't
what was it you weren't even watching
the show where are you what happened
what show were you walking back watching
backstage i was doing my makeup what
happened
we had a little uh blowup and i had to
take off all my clothes and i got
completely naked you missed
so
it
what i saw on the monitor just a little
bit of that i was saying no not a little
bit of anything
well no i wasn't saying that
not vienna this is not going well yes it
is it's going better than you think yes
it is uh first of all i want to start
off by uh happy birthday uh your
birthday was when two days ago uh yes
two days ago
um
happy birthday thank you very much the
big four owned
the big four
okay yes did you have a nice party did
you do anything fun
actually i had a very quiet day i
listened to a little chopin
and maria callis and i had a fitting at
six o'clock i had cake the hotel sent me
a beautiful cake up and
i just had a very quiet it's nice some
people like to be a little low-key about
it and not go crazy i like a lot of
attention and a lot of
god you're great i mean it never happens
yeah sometimes you like a party but i
just wanted to be quiet this year so
today i'm i'm reading about you and a
lot of the things i knew what i did not
know is you have
17 grammys
17 grams
that's just
i thought she would want to say children
oh no no
17 grammys what do you do with 17
grammys
where do you keep them first of all you
put them in a beautiful display
cabinet and you keep them all polished
up and nice i think when you have like
four or five or one you can keep them in
a cabinet if you got 17 i'd have five in
a cabinet and i'd be using the rest
around the house for craft projects for
who's just smashing walnuts with them oh
no no no oh yeah i like seasonings sure
exactly right a little grammy seasoning
boom yeah right no you like to cook you
could use it as an implementation cook i
love to cook what do you like to cook
everything um indian soul
um
you name it you like you like barbecue
too you cook a good bar barbecue do you
have like a secret recipe or anything
like that or do you just pretty much
you're keeping that to yourself
actually no you men are the ones that
have secret recipes for barbecue sauce
right we just put beer
our secret recipe is that needs more
beer and vodka i ever want to tell you
what's in it yeah but no i i just put
mine in
a little white vinegar water just to
make it tender and it's falling off the
bone once you take it off the grill and
it's falling off please make me some of
that sometimes i have such a weakness
for a good barbecue i just start crying
like a baby i'll do that i'm going to
hold you to that i'm going to your house
sometimes ringing ringing the doorbell
and saying where's my barbecue and
security guards will take me away
you're going to get a fedex box full of
barbecue no
i sent you some pulled pork through the
mail
that is not a good way to do it
everybody sent me some chitlins through
fantastic oh they did they're like i
didn't open it for a couple of weeks and
then i got around to it it looked so
straight that's no thanks
you know you're
you're in this very rare category
uh where you you're just all you have to
do is say the first name aretha is here
i think only you and i are in this
category
it's the only two of us left there's
only two queens of soul left and it is
us
it's true you just hear aretha's here
and no one ever you know aretha's gonna
sing tonight no one ever says who which
one
you know aretha mcgillicuddy
what's up
you